leave motivation hey it's Evan
Carmichael and this channel was created
to help you overcome the number one
challenge that is holding you back a
lack of belief in yourself you watch
these videos because you know there's
something more inside you you've got
Michael Jordan level talent at something
so get ready to get honest with yourself
live to your fullest potential and be
willing to be misunderstood with David
Goggins and my take on his top 10 rules
to success volume 14 joy
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one then get honest with yourself who
knows that you have to have thick skin
to get better you have to call yourself
out if you're fat and you're tough
I want to hear that I don't want to hear
you tap dancing around and a lot of
people don't want to go there they don't
want to talk about the childhood then
we'll talk about their past everyone get
to root the problems and then they go
why am I not getting better because
there's a lot of sin that you haven't
dealt with brother you know people go to
the gym like for instance going through
any kind of Special Operations school
these people go to the gym they get big
they get jacked they can run fast all
that but the only thing is doing is
they're coding over the mind all you're
doing is building a bigger stronger
quitter your mind hasn't got any
stronger because you haven't gone back
in there and dealt with so second
adversity comes like my god I'm so fit
what's wrong your mind is still soft
rule number two live up to your fullest
potential
my purpose right now is to continue I
used to have a wash rag and I did this
and you know how to take a shower you
have a wash rag in the cloth and you uh
you're sitting there and you just
lathering up and before you hang your
rag up you want to get all the water to
come on it and you know get it all all
that other suds out of it you want to
wring it out and you want to hang it up
so my big thing is when I lived my life
I want to make sure that when I'm dead
and gone that I read that wash rag out
and that Rosburg is my soul and I also
believe that we're going to end up one
day meeting the maker if you believe in
one and I believe that maker knows
everything about you everything about
you know
Kabir as talking to you knows everything
but you also have a choice to make
you have a choice to make we have
choices and the one thing that scares me
to death in my life is getting to heaven
and not being what I was supposed to be
and I believe that God has a chart and
he looks at the chart and he puts it in
front of you he get to heaven he says
hey that's what you're supposed to be
and one of my biggest fears in life was
to see that chart and not have every
block checked off hmm you know I want to
make sure that I'm constantly pursuing
whatever it is I'm pursuing just to be
the best icon just constantly grinding
myself into a fine powder rule number
three be willing to be misunderstood
I'll tell you one thing if you want to
be great want to be bad ever at what you
do
you could be misunderstood by everybody
because you're gonna be so obsessed is
so driven to get there that's what it
takes that's the trick takes every
second of your life anybody says balance
yeah balance is important for a lot of
people it is but if you want to go to
that edge where people do not like you
don't understand you question everything
you do you you've arrived when you are
misunderstood to the point where people
think you're psycho and you're nuts and
you're this net why are you in the gym
at 1 o'clock in the morning you've got
to doing an OP for 13 14 hours after
Ranger school man at the gym what's
wrong you will never understand what is
wrong with me and that's why I'm so glad
you don't because I'm in the right spot
when people don't understand you anymore
you're in that spot of obsession and
drive or people that quit tough cuz well
this guy I want to talk to you man cuz
you're not gonna get it you're not gonna
get it
boom don't want you to get it yeah that
want you to get it rule number four
don't live in your victories and people
wonder why am I not achieving more it's
because what you what all of us once
reaching something we celebrate for a
long years time and we wonder why don't
I have Drive anymore where's it all at
if you don't develop
a routine of suffering is suffering now
like go out and kill yourself every day
it's being uncomfortable yeah that keeps
you hungry everyday if you live in your
victories for so long and say I'm gonna
go challenge myself for 30 days or for
two weeks or one this run this one
marathon and it is I did one marathon
okay that's why it leaves you it leaves
you because you have to set up the next
obstacle obstacles is how you grow you
must continue to have friction friction
is where growth is at with no friction
there's no growth I love that no growth
also if you want to have more motivation
and self-love checking my 254 series
they're free the link to join or in the
description below everything I didn't
want to do is what got me to where I'm
at today you can outwork anybody it's
about what you're saying to yourself but
it also comes at work so whenever I was
getting beat down physically mentally
spiritually whatever I was going through
just saying you know I would put you
know you can't hurt me
rule number five master the head game
what's the impact that you want to have
in the world the impact that one have in
the world is for everybody to be able to
face who they are I won't have that kind
of impact where you can go on TV you can
put your life on a billboard you're not
ashamed of who the you are not ashamed
of what life made you what you helped
life make you all that [ __ ] all that bad
that's now in this big pot that's
stirring you're no longer ashamed of it
you realize we're all up stop judging
yourself against other people who have
hidden it better than you it's all
they've done they've masters better than
you have and now they're flipping it
back on you and saying you're up I want
you to realize that this world life is
one big head game and once you learn to
play them in head game there's no longer
game anymore at all you can start living
your life rule number six don't be
fueled by anger this is easy - look at
you and that guy's that guy is lit up
and resentment even a shack in the day
so I gotta say I've never seen this
before I was actually telling my fiancee
this the other day people think anger
was my fuel just so yeah anger can be a
fuel anger got me to look into things to
become better I want to show him about
tell you one thing when you're suffering
and you're at the wit's end and you want
to quit that anger is going brother
well it's also not a sustainable fuel
knowers your mind is thinking about
let's get the [ __ ] out of here so I
realized this anger H I didn't think I
my dad beat me up I need my kids coming
they're gotta think about it I thought
my man water is cold as balls now get
the [ __ ] outta here
so I realized anger was no fuel for me
it may have got me to say I want to be
somebody anger got me caught up in some
serious ego chips man rule number seven
get outside your comfort zone when I was
in sixth grade I started real bad
severely bad fifth sixth grade fourth
grade horrible yep like my hair would
fall out why splashes over my skin
horrible horrible anxiety so me talking
about myself as much as I am on stage on
podcast I'm still overcoming you're
still battling because it's comfortable
for me to say I'm office so to me it
don't talk to me I'm good
go back to be my hermit this is very
uncomfortable so I'm constantly coming
outside of my comfort zones and doing
this stuff now sharing my story with
people as much as I can
rule number eight be mindful of your
body you had to be on a constant
reminder almost like how you put a
reminder your phone fifteen minutes you
got this there has to be in your brain
you've done too much stop hmm and what
happens in life is that we start to see
our lives become so successful we're
making money we're doing this we're
doing that I want more I want more I
push harder I'm all about pushing hard
don't get me wrong
obviously I'm all about it but to push
as hard as you can you have to be
mindful of the Machine that's pushing it
is going to end
dying and then it takes years to get it
back so you lose that time Tony that
time is gone you know I lost five years
of I could be crushing it
where now I'm just now back to crushing
it realizing God man I learned the hard
way that's really sometimes one way to
learn rule number nine have a savage
mindset
I just finished a level 100 mile race
just race with all the ups and downs
there's two kind of mindsets we have
under load under load under stress what
mindsets of brutal mindset that rid of
mindset gives you all these ways out oh
I don't need to finish the race I can
come back next year I'm gonna drop out
because things aren't going right the
also a SAP his mind said the sap is
mindset is this like in the house the
house give these mulberries walls some
people aren't really educated
load-bearing walls do a remodel into the
house they tear the load-bearing wall
down the house crumples that's the
brittle mind the sap is my seventh piece
of gold
bad guess what they do quitting's out of
the question
all they think about is have them get
through this there's no quitting
it's just get through it thriving that's
surviving and you'll number 10 the last
one before a very special bonus clip is
structure your day so walk me through a
day in the life what's it look like
right now
no I mean it's got to be crazy right now
I leave here and I fly out to Oregon and
I'll be an organ with Cameron Hayes will
be getting after for a few days a lot
more podcast lot more interviews but
every day every morning I get up I still
get my run in every morning how do you
structure the training the training is
basically structured off of my schedule
so look at my schedule yeah that's okay
Jennifer we have today we have this at
seven o'clock in the morning Roger that
that means I gotta be up by 4 o'clock in
the morning to run that's how it works
that's all my works so she lays out the
schedule of events to out you just you
just set it two hours earlier
she says it could take an hour to get to
rich rolls let's say we were seven
o'clock today in the morning it takes an
hour to get to rich rolls with no
traffic okay that's that's blocking an
hour 15 for rich roll okay we got that
good morning time I'm gonna run seven
miles this morning I need
52:34 that Roger that put in
shower shave add that in so the schedule
dictates but I have always auto-ship
back right so that means getting up at
1:30 trust me Roger that I've done that
several times yeah
how much sleep do you usually get I like
getting 7 to 8 hours of sleep nowadays I
can do that but there's times where the
schedule says hey man you're getting
three hours and if that's the case right
Merry Christmas now I have a special
bonus clip from David on how to find
your equation that I think you're gonna
enjoy but before that is time for the
three-point landing questions let's go
from just watching the video to taking
action here we go question number one
how can you better structure your day
number two where do you need to be more
mindful of your body and number three
what will you do this week to get
outside your comfort zone and if you
promise to take action after watching
this video we don't just watch videos
anymore we do something after watching
them
give me a hash tag believe down the
comments make that promise to yourself
and then get to work I believe all of us
humans have an equation like you know pi
is 3.14 that's how you solve for that
equation every human being has a
different equation and there's not like
some cookie cutter book of hey read this
book and you'll be fixed know you got to
figure out your own personal equation
and once you figure out that equation
you now become a mathematical genius
about yourself
if you want more David Goggins check out
the top 50 rules video I made on him the
link is right there next to me I think
you'll enjoy it continue to believe and
I'll see you there
the whole thing about comfort zones is
if you live in one for too long that
becomes your norm you can outwork
anybody how badass